by the article just came out by
Washington Post
U.S workers have gotten way less
productive no one is sure why oh really
okay now we have no clue because we have
no clue why the employee you know
employees have gotten unproductive you
know in the first half of 2020 to
productivity the measure of how much
outputting goods and services an
employee can produce in an hour plunged
by the sharpest raid on record going
back to 1947 according to data from the
Bureau of Labor Statistics it also
raises new questions about the shift to
hybrid schedules and remote work oh
possible questions yeah I mean that's
definitely not that as employees have
made the case that flexibility help them
work from more effectively and it comes
at a time when quiet quitting doing only
what's expected
and no more is resonating especially
with younger workers no one knows or
will know what is causing the drop-off
in productivity for some time said
Economist Lawrence H Summers president
emmer he's this is this is supposed to
be a smart person here saying
I know I know who he is no he was under
the uh uh
no one knows or will know why what is
causing the drop-off and productivity
for some time said Economist Larry
Summers uh uh but he was a former
treasury secretary but it could have
something to do with the fact that many
employees were working unsustainable
hard in 2020 and 2021. oh my God
Larry the Larry that statement there
there was something missing after a
night of hard drinking with Paul Pelosi
he said but it could have something to
do with the back then pleasure but you
know what's this is BS because which way
does he wasn't does he want to say he he
contradicts himself is quiet quitting
doing what it only what is expected and
more that was the work from home thing
and then he wants to say but they were
working unsustainably hard in 20 years
let me say this you can't use both sides
of his mouth if you're seven years old
if you're seven years old you're 10
years old and your mom's best friend
brings her ten-year-old daughter over to
your house your 10 she's 10. and you're
upstairs in your room if your mom and
her mom are okay with you being upstairs
for two hours what do you think
eventually is happening okay well what's
the rule don't close the door don't let
me the kid stay in there so you know
don't let them be by themselves nobody
else if you want to play you guys can
play downstairs in front of us right
here while you're 10 years old you ain't
going upstairs hey Mom hey Dad are you
guys okay if I go in the room with Mary
and close the door and lock it up
because we feel we're gonna be more
productive here Mom yeah go ahead guys
go ahead and close the door and do this
yeah yeah yeah okay we trust you so much
I think we'll be productive for the same
bosses it's not even though they're
gonna play what is that game you know
doctor whatever so the point is to the
bosses that actually bought into this
you know to the bosses that actually
bought into this and said oh this is a
very effective method really really like
maybe you want to be less productive
yeah maybe secretly you want to work
from home so you can tell everybody what
to do so you can watch more Netflix so
you can watch do you know how often
nowadays I walk by people right even the
environment here or our insurance
company I'll walk by cubicles you know
how many employees I'll see sometimes
they're just watching a movie while
they're doing their work oh really you
know what yeah I'm sorry about that no
no I'm sitting I'm like I'm like what is
this guy doing the videos the videos I
don't want to give names because people
are going to go upstairs I'm like what's
this guy doing he's watching a movie
we had an editor who would always have
mistakes and things he would do with
different I love this guy yeah but every
day he would watch three movies oh you
cannot stay focused and watch more so if
you're watching movies at work if you're
watching movies at work and you're
watching shows at work what the hell you
think people are doing their home by
themselves you think maybe listen I'm
gonna take a 20 minute nap and unless I
was at the restroom yeah hey babe come
over why just who cares they're not
gonna know anyways just come over let's
spend some time together you know what
I'm gonna go over here on Xbox and have
a cup of coffee and take a three-hour
lunch break I wanna what do you think is
going to be happening so again this is
when
being naive gets exposed and people no
longer use logic to think someone's
going to be more productive at home
every article two years ago year and a
half ago was people are being more
creative and productive working from
home I can't tell you how many
presentations I got from managers that
work with me saying Patrick we're going
to do much better if we get people to
work from home no we're not
no we're not no one is more productive
working from home than be working from
the office now some people are
independent contractors that do what
they do and they're based on projects
and all the fine I'm not talking about
that for the most part there's a reason
why workers have gone less productive
um I'm sure I think there's two sides of
the equation here there's and by the way
yeah go ahead a week here remember a
week ago on the podcast we talked about
that software company where the
engineers working from home path they
were using it is covered I have two jobs
ah so you take eight hours in a day but
I'm paid for 16. I call that 50
productivity right it's pretty people
having two jobs that's simple simple
math two jobs paid 16 hours worked eight
that's fifteen percent I actually
respect those people because they are
busting their ass two jobs we expect I
mean most that's what it is by the way
it is what percentage of people are
doing that that's very creative 99 are
working less but quick shout out to Paul
E I know he's probably uh listening
right now if he's uh not watching a
movie but there's two sides to this
there's a productivity side but there's
also the culture side of things right
could you imagine if I think that we
here at valuetainment not only are we
creating content and filming stuff and
and everything that you see the podcast
but there's also the other side of
things it's the culture that we're
creating it's the teamwork it's the
environment it's the friendships if
you're doing that at your company
and everything's remote there's no
culture there's no teamwork there's no
oh we got this thing going on here once
a month we do team meetings you talked
about uh Lincoln on leadership
circulating the troops and hey man how
you feeling blah blah blah like that's
also a part of a company yeah so it's
um not just the productivity yeah going
with each other cop Golf and getting
outside work you have to do you have to
be in front of the person to find out by
the way listen it's very simple if you
want to work in an environment where
they want to let you work remote those
companies are out there go find them go
find them we're not one it's I'm very
okay with that but for people the same
people that said I don't know why maybe
because they work so hard in 2020 and
2021. I can guarantee you people didn't
work hard in 2020 and 24. it's the least
working years in the last two three four
decades because they got away with
everything working from home ain't
nobody very few people in 2020 and 2021
were working harder than they're working
if you're working and your bed is right
there the TV's there and the couch is
there yeah and the refrigerator also the
bong is right there they're close by the
alcohol people are coming over you're
doing a zoom with them any reason why
your eyes are so red yeah it's just been
a very stressful day yeah man yeah I'm
just woke up dude you know it's
interesting the news media pushes The
Narrative of workers to the World Unite
you know leave them alone let them work
from home they're gonna be more
productive they put all this as BS was
very very interesting there there was a
gentleman that ran the um the
unfortunate amalgamation of uh Yahoo and
AOL that was bought by Verizon and Pat
you know what he found he found that the
recent college graduates so the ones
that were like less than five years out
of college Pat they were always asking
when can I'm working hard and I'm doing
more when can I get a
oh you can get a raise if I choose to
promote how do I get the promotion and
then they wanted FaceTime with their
boss they wanted to be seen they wanted
to be doing their little meetings and
have their boss walk by and see that
they were working with their team that
didn't work working from home and there
is Beyond The Narrative of the news
media Pat there were people that were
just five years out of school that were
not looking for Kush they were looking
to be seen and they wanted to know how
they got promoted and they want to make
more money because they weren't content
with where they were and nobody wants to
talk about this but this stuff was
happening and you know my hat's off to
them but they don't get coverage so if
you like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
[Music]